hey what's up everybody it's warren and
happy new year's eve to everybody this
morning i woke up with
a ton of dms and emails in regards to
the wolverine being an avengers end game
rumor that is going viral right now
i acknowledge that other youtubers have
done videos on this
already i believe my boy michael roman
at everything always was the first
person to do it
but again it's a huge rumor going around
right now everybody's talking about it
and so many people have asked me about
it so in this video i'm going to explain
what is happening
and i'll give you my own take on it but
before we get started today
is the last day to enter the giveaway to
win a life-sized infinity gauntlet i
will be picking a winner tomorrow on
january
1st new year's day so if you would like
to enter for your chance to win
all you have to do is subscribe to my
channel like the video and comment down
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero
okay so here's what has everybody going
just absolutely insane right now
if you go to google and you type in the
google search bar hugh jackman
famous movies and click enter a ton of
movies will come up at the top
hugh jackman is a great actor he's been
acting for a very long time so you'll
see a lot of movies pop up including
logan and his x-men movies but if you go
to the right and click the arrow
you can see that avengers end game pops
up so this is why everybody is freaking
out they're saying this confirms that
hugh jackman will be in avengers in game
as wolverine
so i'll go ahead and give you my
personal thoughts on this and
one is this does not confirm it and it
pains me to say that i'm not saying it
won't happen i'm just saying this does
not confirm it
google does not always have an actual
person placing these movies on this list
for example if this gets searched enough
it'll automatically pop
up due to google search results so this
does not mean that hugh jackman will be
in avengers endgame and if you search on
imdb
and other movie credit sites he is
nowhere to be found
so that points to this showing up on
google search
simply because people are searching for
it so if you hear other people say it's
confirmed hugh jackman will be in
avengers in-game as wolverine
it's not sadly but could it happen yes
it could the disney fox deal is just
about done it is set to be wrapped up in
january
and the deal is so close to being done
that people at marvel are actually
beginning to talk about the x-men and
the fantastic four being in the mcu
and i've stated this in a few videos
actually just because disney and marvel
don't own the rights to use a character
doesn't mean
that they can't work out a deal to be
able to use that character they've
actually done this before they did a
deal for deadpool and guardians of the
galaxy vol 2.
fox allowed disney and marvel to use ego
and disney and marvel allowed fox to use
negasonic teenage warhead and also
change her powers
so could a deal have been worked out to
be able to use wolverine in avengers end
game
yes absolutely especially since he's
coming home to marvel so soon anyways
but this is just speculation this is in
no way
a confirmation but people are asking if
it's even possible
yes it is possible however unlikely it
is it is still possible and then people
were asking me
why they would do this is this their way
to introduce x-men into the mcu do it in
avengers end game
i don't think that's their mindset kevin
feige has already said that he wouldn't
want to introduce wolverine first into
the mcu he actually stated that he would
like to do the fantastic four
first so i don't think it would be for a
sole purpose to introduce
mutants into the mcu going forward but i
think it would be more along the lines
that
wolverine is actually in the infinity
gauntlet series in the comics
in the comics there are many x-men going
against thanos with the avengers
in fact most of them suffer pretty
intense deaths
wolverine and the hulk have some pretty
intense battles throughout the comics
but in the beginning of the infinity
gauntlet saga where adam warlock is
trying to get all of the heroes to come
together to fight against thanos they
actually become friends
hulk says to wolverine you and i we've
had some down and dirty scraps
you fight someone you get to know them
pretty well and i've come to the
conclusion
i like you shorty wolverine asks why's
that and the hulk says because in our
own ways we're both monsters pal
unfortunately this friendship was
short-lived because they would soon meet
their demise against thanos
wolverine actually almost kills thanos
but unfortunately thanos has the
infinity gauntlet so with the simple
thought of his mind
thanos turns all of the adamantium and
wolverine's body to rubber so he just
sort of flops to the ground
helpless but the point i'm making is
that wolverine actually plays a pretty
big part in the fight against thanos in
the infinity gauntlet series
so it's not too far-fetched of an idea
for wolverine to be in avengers endgame
and there's actually been some theories
that the marks on thanos's face
are from wolverine he already has a lot
of marks on his face due to the deviant
gene that he inherited but if you look
on the left and
right side of his face you can see three
scars going down
so some people are saying that wolverine
actually already exists in the mcu and
has already fought thanos at one point
in time
the logic being that thanos does not
have these marks in the comics but he
does in the mcu
and they look like they would be claw
marks from wolverine
so how did he get them perhaps thanos
has fought wolverine before
so there is a way for wolverine to be an
avengers in game and there also
is a reason for him to be in avengers in
game as well
however saying all of that i do not
think he will make an appearance in
avengers end game
again the google search doesn't confirm
anything and i actually think that
google will eventually realize it's
there and take it down
and although the russo brothers and
kevin feige have said that we're going
to see some new characters in avengers
in-game i don't think it would be such a
huge character as wolverine
since end game is wrapping up the first
10 years of the mcu
they're going to want to keep the focus
on the heroes that we love
and although i know everyone would love
to see wolverine in avengers in game i
think it would take too much away from
our current heroes
and if some of them are going to die or
retire i think we should give them
the full respect they deserve so this is
why everybody is freaking out right now
talking about wolverine being
in avengers endgame you can go to google
and do that search yourself but let me
know what you think about this
do you think hugh jackman is going to be
in avengers end game as wolverine or do
you not think so
let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below and again very last
day to enter the infinity gauntlet
giveaway all you have to do to enter for
your chance to win is subscribe to my
channel
like this video and comment down below
with your thoughts and your favorite
superhero
again happy new year's eve and as always
thank you so much for watching
wolf wolf
[Music]
you